So, in our approach to a patient with multiple rashes...
...it is important for us to examine certain body parts...
...that may give us clues to the diagnosis.
So, one example is to make sure we look at the nails and examine the nails of our patient...
...to look for any hints that could signify certain diseases.
Ma'am, is it okay if I take a look at your elbows?
We also want to examine her scalp.
In this patient with multiple rashes with a known diagnosis of psoriasis...
...and with some clinical lesions, classic for psoriasis on her elbows and scalp,...
...it can be difficult to understand whether or not other rashes are related to that same diagnosis.
To recap, we see multiple diagnoses and we need to approach each one independently...
...as if they are the only rash.
You'll often have patients with multiple and complex rashes.
These rashes don't need to be confusing.
You just need to approach each rash one at a time...
...by describing primary morphology and supportive attributes.